[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
chaque semaine sur les temps forts de
l'actualité à l'assemblée et au sénat
est avec moi pour présenter cette
émission steve jourdain bonjour style
bonjour brigitte est notre invité
aujourd'hui c'est rachid tu es mal
bonjour à tchité mal vous êtes sénateur
socialiste du val d'oise et c'est steve
qui dresse votre portrait racheter mal
vous êtes né à eaubonne dans le val
d'oise c'est dans ce département que
vous avez fait vos premières armes en
politique votre maison c'est le parti
socialiste secrétaire de section premier
fédéral secrétaire national à partir de
2014 premier secrétaire par intérim en
2007 2017 c'est une mauvaise année un
pour le parti socialiste mais plutôt une
bonne année pour vous puisque au mois
d'octobre vous êtes élu sénateur
les élections c'est un peu votre domaine
d'expertisé vous avez été secrétaire
adjoint aux élections au sein du ps et
vous n'aimez pas qu'on dise en parlant
des dernières municipales qu'on a
assisté à une vague verte pourquoi c'est
pas que j'aime ou j'aime pas ce la
politique c'est pas ça c'est il ya des
faits il ya une progression de machault
heureux que quand des partenaires
progresse il ya une progression manifes
notables et sensible d'europe écologie
les verts mais après il faut regarder la
réalité de l'ensemble municipal
aujourd'hui si on prend la gauche
le premier réseau d'élu local et de très
très très très loin c'est le parti sa
liste donc le paralyse depuis 2014 ces
dernières élections nous avons progressé
dans mon département par exemple est
donc partout et je pourrais citer
beaucoup de george michael delafosse à
montpellier mathieu klein à nancy et je
prends dans le lit de france vous avez
par exemple karine - bram à saint-ouen
me mathieu hanotin saint denis on a déjà
zaz à châtillon belle victoire et puis
dans mon département des screen en aura
a besoin je vous en serais beaucoup
d'autres donc à une nouvelle génération
qui arrive est choisie est une bonne
chose
voilà donc moi je vous ai fait d'accord
avec olivier forbes pour vous c'est il
est hors de question de se mettre à la
remorque des écologistes pour les envies
des prochaines élections
avant mon positionnement n'est pas par
rapport à untel ou untel je respecte
beaucoup d'amitié pour les premiers
secrétaires du personnel je dis
simplement que l'élection de la
prochaine élection présidentielle elle
sera très important notre pays et je
crois que les socialistes mais il faut
renouveler notre pensée il faut un
projet socialiste et je voudrais donc
forcément j'ai derrière un candidat il
associait les écologistes
mehdi olivier faure moi je ne sais pas
ce qu'a sociale écologiste jusqu'à
preuve du contraire parti socialiste est
un parti européen qu'il faut un candidat
socialiste je pense qu'aujourd'hui je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les verts et
apporte une réponse partielle
un son de problématiques et je crois que
nous socialistes avant de réponse plus
globale il faut réinventer fin de vos
projets socialistes pour la france
et après on discutera que les
partenaires moi je pense que si j'étais
si je pensais que ce que propose
socialiste était plus opérants que ce
qu'est la social démocratie
je serai chez les verts je suis
socialiste parce que je pense que la
question d'égalité la question sociale
la question d'émancipation la laïcité
etc et milliards une priorité majeure
dont je suis socialiste et je pense que
ce projet-là correspond mieux aux
français qu'un autre projet ça me semble
juste cohérent et je crois que le je
crois quand vous êtes militant d'un
parti politique peut le comprendre
sinon avec les socialistes et les
écologistes à vos plats bas donc moi je
le pense qu'il faut faire par étapes
première chose c'est un projet
socialiste parce que je pense qu'il faut
qu'il entende je pense que votre ombre
présente aux français ce qu'est notre
vision pour la france pour le monde pour
l'europe
ça c'est le premier point après s'il ya
une primaire de la gauche
faisons là mais sinon s'il n'y a pas de
primaire s'il n'y a pas que les
socialistes qu'elle serait donc la forme
et la méthode pour désigner un candidat
et un projet oui moi j'essaie d'être
cohérent et moi-même allé tout de suite
les titres de cette émission la
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
la gestion de l'épidémie de kobe 19 a
pris une tournure plus politique cette
semaine à l'assemblée agnès buzyn
répondu aux tirs nourris des députés
redistribuer les pouvoirs renforcés les
collectivités locales gérard larcher a
présenté les 50 propositions du sénat
pour une nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation fin de la technique de
la clé d'étranglement à partir du 1er
septembre pourquoi christophe castaner
at il décidé d'y mettre fin directeur
général de la police a répondu aux
questions des sénateurs
on l'entendra allez on commence cette
émission avec la commission d' enquête
sur la gestion de l'épidémie de
coronavirus à l'assemblée
[Musique]
après les experts les politiques étaient
auditionnés cette semaine par la
commission d' enquête sur la gestion de
la crise du coc vide 4 ministre de la
santé se sont succédé mais c'est agnès
buzyn qui a eu le plus de mal à
convaincre les députés
nathalie guy loire je le jure c'est sur
un ton solennel canis busan se défend
face aux députés au coeur du débat la
question de la gestion des masques
durant son audition l'ancien ministre de
la santé affirme avoir anticipé la crise
mais la connaissance exacte des stocks
elle estime que ce n'est pas de sa
responsabilité en réalité je n'ai pas à
savoir la quantité ni disponible ni
nécessaire des dizaines voire centaines
de produits gérés en réponse aux risques
sanitaires parce que ils sont
extrêmement nombreux une version moins
de convaincre ses prédécesseurs ils sont
trois anciens ministres de la santé à
avoir été auditionné cette semaine et
tous estiment qu à cette fonction ils
sont responsables de tout depuis la loi
de 2007 c'est au ministre ou à son
représentant de s'assurer justement que
le nombre de mâts ce que ce sera
suffisant
évidemment une ministre ne va pas
compter les ampoules mais une ministre
elle marque des orientations
elle prend des arbitrages et elle est
amenée à certains moments à poser des
questions et à regarder sur certains
sujets qui lui sont posées quelle est la
position qu'elle prendre est-ce que
ministre c'est être au courant de tout
oui oui c'est être au courant de tout et
si on n'est pas au courant de quelque
chose s'arranger pour le savoir qui des
auditions qui ont mis en difficulté le
discours tenu par agnès buzyn lors de
son audition tous à leur façon ont
souligné les failles de la gestion de
crise notamment concernant les matchs
karachi tu es mal est-ce que vous avez
été convaincu par agnès buzyn nom à lui
dire la crise agnès b il ya deux choses
elle c'est eux j'allais dire elle a fait
l'interview dans le monde qui était
catastrophique où allah comme dit des
choses invraisemblables pour une
ancienne
istres la santé et puis devant les
députés elle a donné le sentiment d dans
l'auto satisfecit
c'était assez bizarre mais elle a pas
suffisamment préparé la france n'avait
pas été convaincu quand elle a expliqué
qu'elle avait été une des premières à
alerter par rapport aux autres pays
européens
ce que ne comprend pas c'est qu'elle ce
qu'elle nous dit d'un côté j'ai informé
le président puis a pas eu de réaction
quand on les français voient ce qui
s'est passé sur la première vague les
morts les difficultés un pays à l'arrêt
et puis tout ça faut pas oublier il ya
une note de monsieur salomon qui en
2016-2017 dit que la france n'est pas
prête à un événement de cette nature là
la question c'est que ce qui s'est passé
pendant trois ans que s'est passé en
trois ans est ce qu est ce qu un
ministre tout savoir on parle des
rapports entre politique
d'administration elle a souvent relancer
enfin remis la balle dans le camp de
l'administration selon vous à quel est
leur rôle d'un ministre ce qu'elle pense
quand on est ministre comme emma sur le
touraine à la fin donne des orientations
dont on doit également ont impulsé en
temps doit avoir une capacité de
direction à diriger il est surtout
d'assumer mizdah je crois qu'un siad
combien il ya de masques à un instant t
en france cerveau en tout cas quand vous
êtes sur des sujets aussi importants qui
est est ce que la france ait préparé un
événement de cette nature je crois que
vous avez un cabinet vous avez une
station mais en responsabilité c'est le
ministre responsable
et quand on voit ce qu'on voit on aurait
eu droit parce que il faut se souvenir
du début de la crise où les gens d'aller
brême était plutôt en train d'expliquer
que c'est la faute du moment précédent
comme à chaque fois d'ailleurs avec eux
ce n'est jamais de leur faute
bien sûr qu'on se rend compte patatras
que finalement c'est un peu de la faute
et qui a eu des soucis effectivement
accès gestion et moi je pense qu'en plus
il faut faire merci de transparence on
le doit je pense aux français était plus
encore à ceux qui ont été reconnus la
maladie les familles qui ont été eux
sont décédés mais moi mon objectif d'une
commission enquête j'ai demandé celle au
sénat c'est la faire comprendre ce qui
s'est passé et peut aussi préparer la
france bleu la france se dire dorénavant
quand il ya un incident à ce qu'on
appelle un signe au fait un signal
faible dans un pays
comment la france cette incapacité à
détecter de prendre des modèles et de
prendre les problèmes première les
commission denquête quand vous voyez là
les ministres qui se renvoient
finalement les responsabilités est-ce
que ça n'affaiblit pas l'ensemble du
monde politique bassana faiblit pas mais
personne n'est responsable final si
forcément des responsabilités et
les pointes et puis après tout cette
omission dans lequel elle a pour but de
désigner des coupables
c'est pas désignés coupables ces deux
dans un premier temps de désigner est ce
qu'il ya eu des dispositifs des choses
des failles des défaillances
la réponse est oui d'ailleurs le prise
en lumière la république lui même l'a
dit dans une intervention il faut quand
vous pointer les défaillances il ya des
responsables mais une fois que vous avez
dit ça la question c'est comment on fait
en sorte qu'il n'est plus à l'avenir
vous parliez réussite est mal de la
commission denquête au sénat quelle est
la différence entre la commission
denquête au sénat qui va qui va faire sa
première audition la semaine prochaine
et la commission à l'assemblée nationale
bon allez c'est là se dérouler on verra
à la fin je sais c'est pas absurde ou de
méthode
alain milon le président de la
commission des affaires sociales et qui
va présider cette commission enquête
parle de dépassionner les débats c'est
possible pour un sujet aussi sensible
moi je pense que il faut dépassionner
mais des passionnés en étant en
rigoureux et je voulais dit en pointant
ce qui n'a pas fonctionné et le pourquoi
et en préparant la france mieux à de
nouvelles méthodes et un risque nouveau
je pense qu'il faut porter mes jours
j'ai la faiblesse de penser alors je
suis dans la maison à la semaine
nationale et je sais qu'au sénat ya
aussi une très très grande rigueur et je
crois que notamment sur la sphère
benalla il ya une petite différence
parce que d'un côté vous avez une
majorité qui est celle du présent et
public ici à l'assemblée
et puis l'autre côté vous avez aussi des
gens qui sont pas attachés au prix
qu'ils peuvent peut-être travailler avec
un peu plus de liberté mais moi je
respecte et 2 commission denquête il ya
deux champs chacun peut aller un peu
plus loin mettre en exergue talent tel
ou tel point moi je pense que c'est ça
la démocratie
je voudrais vous faire et elle dira à
roselyne bachelot ministre de la santé
de 2007 à 2010 elle a porté une attaque
contre tout ce qu'ils attendent tous
deux laitages propose de l'écouter
j'ai entendu un représentant d'un
syndicat de médecins à dire nous
n'avions pas de masque dans nos cabinets
mais enfin des médecins qui n'ont pas de
masque dans leurs cabinets qui se
constitue pas un stock
nous n'avions pas de blouse m'enfin
pourquoi les médecins ne porte plus de
blues
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est dans ce
pays de pasteur qu'est ce que c'est que
cette médecine
on attend que le préfet le directeur de
la rs viennent avec une petite charrette
porter des masques
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays est
infantilisé il faut quand même un peu se
prendre en main dans ce pays
c'est ça la leçon qu'il faut tirer
l'état ne peut pas tout comme disait
lionel jospin mais ce que les français
attendent tout l'état voilà vous avez un
show de
bachelet moi ce que je sais basque au
pardon ce que je sais c'est que je
prends le cas du val d'oise moi je note
que les médecins les personnels
hospitaliers ont fait beaucoup et ils
ont parfois été abandonné mais je ne
crois pas que ce qu'elles disent tu
entendu ils étaient tous infantiliser
non ils ont aussi beaucoup travaillé et
je pense qu'il faut aussi faire
attention à ce qu'on dit elle a voulu
faire un bon mot je crois qu'ils moi je
sais le plus tôt les personnes de santé
n'est pas que seulement aussi vous avez
des questions ou tout ce qu'ils ont qui
ont pendant des mois ou des semaines et
des semaines pris beaucoup de risques
pour notre santé et pour notre façon de
vivre je crois que plus tôt les saluer
allez on poursuit cette émission avec le
plan de décentralisation présenté par le
président du sénat pour une nouvelle
génération de la décentralisation la
mission est ambitieuse et propositions
sont nombreuses
50 au total gérard larcher a présenté la
vision du sénat pour une réorganisation
de l'état regarder ce sujet les signer
jonathan du prix s sur la
décentralisation le sénat entend montrer
la voie face à la presse gérard larcher
a défendu les 50 mesures de la chambre
haute pour redéfinir l'équilibré des
pouvoirs dans le pays
emmanuel macron avait sollicité le sénat
début juin pour contribuer à sa
réflexion sur l'après autre chose je
vais renverser la table
eh ben nous lui disons moi je lui dis
politiquement chiche
et donc nous sommes dans une attitude
positive attentive en même temps
exigeante et je dis chiche
les sénateurs veulent en finir avec la
gouvernance verticale et l'hyper
centralisation à la française un
cocktail responsable selon eux de
nombreux dysfonctionnements dans la
gestion de la crise sanitaire les
collectivités étaient plus rapides plus
agile plus réactives pour apporter des
solutions besoin bien tirerons les
enseignements de cette crise et
équilibrons les pouvoirs dans notre pays
en permettant aux collectivités de faire
ce que l'état n'a pas su faire ou ne
sait pas faire
les parlementaires proposent ainsi de
délégués de nouvelles compétences aux
collectivités en matière d'emploi ou de
santé notamment
il propose par exemple de soumettre les
ars à l'autorité des régions les
sénateurs
post aussi d'inscrire dans la
constitution le principe du qui paie
décide pour assurer aux collectivités
leur autonomie financière
autre préconisation l'inscription dans
la constitution de l'ensemble des
compétences des maires des annonces
ciblées à destination des élus locaux
à quelques semaines des sénatoriales
c'est très bien qu'il en soit ainsi et
c'est attendu et on attend que le sénat
soit force de proposition ces pistes ont
été remises dans la foulée au président
de la république et se traduiront en
plusieurs propositions de loi dans le
courant du mois de juillet rachid fait
mal c'est 50 propositions ce sont les
propositions de gérard larcher du sénat
ou de la majorité sénatoriale
d'abord il faut savoir que pour les
socialistes au sénat
nous avons déposé un pépère et qui était
adoptable illimité de messiaen de
résolution a raison de rappeler et donc
les socialistes ont fait leurs
propositions d'ailleurs elles sont
annexe au rapport dans le dans les
propositions qui ont été faites hier par
géra chez les choses que nous partageons
des choses quoi globalement sur une
nouvelle génération décentralisation je
rappelle que les socialistes nous avons
été les premiers à la faire avec
françois mitterrand garçons de faire
donc c'est dans notre adn dont le fait
aussi que on puisse clarifier les
compétences entre l'état et les
collectivités que finalement les
colchiques d'une capacité d'autonomie
d'adaptation que soit la loutre mer ou
en métropole dont il ya plein de points
communs
il ya des divergences donc mais moi je
le trouve je trouve que quels sont les
divergences
si vous deviez citer 1 1 point en
particulier je pense que nous nous
sommes plus je pense que notre
culturel est plus importante et je pense
qu'on va plus loin alors je vais pas
vous donner un point au sens où c'est
plutôt l'esprit je crois que en plus
loin moi je peux vous même dire que moi
je vais encore plus loin parce qu'à
titre personnel je suis pour des vrais
parlements régionaux avec députés
régionaux plutôt que des conseils
régionaux comme au journal espagnol
non parce que quand vous donner cet
exemple là ça veut dire que ça devient
une sorte de fédération c'est parce que
je dis je sais bien que tout de suite on
bloque le débattu moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la question qui nous est
posée c'est comment on rapproche le
citoyen de la décision et on le voit est
donc abonnée bon échelon pour ça c'est
le département comme le dit gérard
larcher
moi je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
plusieurs approches vous avez un couple
aujourd'hui qui existe qui est commune
interco ça c'est un premier couple et
puis après on est un couple département
région donc ça il faut regarder comment
ça fonctionne
la question ce n'est pas tant les
chances et la question c'est qui fait
quoi et qui paye quoi je pense que c'est
là qu'il ya un souci de et dans tous les
cas après il faut rapprocher avec le
avec le citoyen la décision le président
la république a donné une interview à la
presse quotidienne régionale où il parle
de différenciation c'est le cas aussi de
gérard larcher vous vous êtes d'accord
il faut différencier selon les
territoires selon les régions ou les
départements
je pense qu'il faut que l'état pose un
cadre ce qui est de sa compétence propre
ce qui est de celles qui a peut être
transféré qui paye comment et après
comment tout ça s'articule il ne
faudrait pas que ce soit une france à
plusieurs vitesses c'est là qu'il faut
trouver le point d'équilibré je voulais
dire à mon parce que il a fait
l'interview prix implique très sympa je
vous invite à lire l'interview parce que
tous ceux qui s'interrogent sur le
virage social ou écologique n'a pas ces
on continue les retraites extérieur à
tous à tout même à une grande conférence
de territoire mais le problème c'est que
avec avec emmanuel okon c'est toujours
la même histoire
il dit les choses il fait autre chose
pour les gens simples sur la
décentralisation
celui qui a fait le pacte de cahors qui
ne fait une vraie recentralisation
financières et administratives et
politiques
c'est emmanuel croes que pouvez vous
retrouver quelque part avec emmanuel
macron sur ce sujet de la
décentralisation et d'un je ne vous le
dira lui la vision centralisée il a dit
je rappelle l'accord de cahors c'est
dorénavant les communes et les
collectivités
pas de progression de +1 22% nos
dépenses quoi qu'il arrive donc la rue
il a mis la tutelle sur les communes
c'est celui qui a retiré la taxe
d'habitation qui a remis une tutelle
fiscale sur les communes ont donc doc
est non si emmanuel macron changé je
viens discuter mais quand je prends les
actes c'est important on en 2020 ça fait
trois ans que les prisons sur la
dépréciation il a fait l'inversé
de ce que nous pensons nous les
socialistes ou ce que pense la chambre
des territoires à savoir le scénario
pourtant vous avez dit qu'ils décident
paix c'est exactement ce qu'a dit
emmanuel macron mais bien souvent l'état
décidé s'ils cotisent paient mais moi ça
me saoule et une augmentation des
dotations n'allait il ya deux choses
emmanuel macron quand tu prends décision
cd cotisé qui pai pai pardon nous ce
qu'on dit c'est que effectivement
abandonnés si on transfère des
politiques publiques à des collectivités
quels que soit l'échelon il faut
qu'elles aient les moyens de les mettre
en place dont pour cela il faut qu'elles
aient les moyens de leur politique
je rappelle que si on prend les communes
dorénavant avec la suppression et
acceptation on a retiré l'essentiel mais
ça a été entièrement compensées par
l'état est d'abord allé pas fini je
rappelle ses compensées à l'instant t
sauf qu'ensuite les côtiers elle
continue à avoir des dépenses
je prends un exemple très simple vous
êtes dans une commune vous développez un
quartier et ses nouveaux quartiers
bon sauf que ça c'est plus intégrée dans
la compensation ça n'existe pas mais
dans ce quartier là il faut développer
des écrans publics une école des pôles
culturels des pôles de santé qui les
payent les communes sans argent
supplémentaire de l'état russe c'est une
mécanique un peu folle la 7h été mal en
quelques mots gérard larcher d'hier
notre pays se fracturent vous les voyez
vous ces fractures vous en france la
première fracture c'est la question
sociale
aujourd'hui il ya cette question sociale
mais je vous dis un autre exemple est
donc moi je vois dans la loi ce parce
que dans la loi n'avait ces mini france
à la fois vous avez des territoires
ruraux et très urbain et moi je vois à
l'aide les fractures mais je prends un
exemple sur l'éducation en france quand
vous avez vous aiderez l'étude pisa puis
l'étude du ministère
les différences des inégalités à la
naissance à lens quand vous rentrez à
l'école sont au mieux au mieux maintenu
à la sortie dont ce qui est pour nous
dans notre idéal républicain moi je suis
républicain c'est l'école qui permet l
émancipation
on voit que l'école globalement bloque
la société française d exception à la
règle bien sûr mais elle bloque c'est un
échec
et donc là c'est pas un exemple de
fracture la question sociale aujourd'hui
les gens de plus en plus riche des ans
de plus en plus pauvres et puis le
sentiment que la république n'est plus
là dire quand vous êtes pour la pluie
que vous dites
la pluie qui permet d'avancer en termes
de services en termes d'écoles the lady
entame transport et il ya deux
sentiments de france à plusieurs
vitesses aller au terme de cette
émission avec la mission d'information
sénatoriale sur les mets
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
à partir du 1er septembre la police ne
pourra plus utiliser la technique dite
de la clé d'étranglement pourquoi
christophe castaner at il décidé d'y
mettre fin quelles techniques de
substitution pour les forces de l'ordre
le directeur général de la police
étaient entendus au sénat jérôme rabier
revient sur les moments forts de cette
audition il a la délicate mission de
protéger les policiers qu'il dirige
mais aussi de rendre des comptes au
ministère de l'intérieur le directeur
général de la police nationale assume
donc cette dernière décision devant la
mission d'information du sénat
oui c'est lui qui a proposé à christophe
castaner d'arrêter l'apprentissage de la
technique dite d'étranglement qui ne
sera donc plus enseignée en école de
police
je suis à l'origine de la proposition
que j'ai faite aux mises à l'intérieur
de d'abandonner cette technique qui est
très impactante pour celle ou celui qui
la subit
et bien sûr aussi très utile pour celle
ou celui qui la met en oeuvre
simplement quand elle est mal maîtrisée
elle peut avoir des conséquences
importantes et donc ma responsabilité ce
n'est pas d'exposer les personnels dont
j'ai la responsabilité sur le terrain
que ce soit en termes de sécurité
physique ou de sécurité juridique
mais pour les sénateurs il ya sans doute
eu de la précipitation dans cette
décision comme l'expliquent le président
de la mission d'information philippe bas
ce qui suscite une certaine
interrogation aujourd'hui c'est que on
décide d'interrompre la formation
à cette technique mais qu'on n'a pas
encore véritablement l'alternative or il
faut que force reste toujours à la loi
un argumentaire qui reprend les plaintes
des syndicats de policiers qui
s'inquiètent de l'abandon de ces
techniques d'interpellation
c'est une des raisons de leur
manifestation récente mais frédéric
veaux tient à les rassurer
il a rappelé aux sénateurs que si la
technique n'est plus enseignée elle peut
encore être utilisé dans la tente d'une
technique de remplacement pour laquelle
les fonctionnaires de police devront
être formés rachid tu es mal fin de la
clé d'étranglement vous saluer ce choix
de christophe castaner c'est très
compliqué parce que dit on le voit dans
votre reportage encore une fois on voit
un gouvernement qui est dans la
précipitation puisque on annonce la fin
de cette crise très bien mais on n'y a
pas de solution poser à la place donc en
fait moi je pense qu'il faut se mettre
les choses très clairement un
il faut rappeler que les forces de
police c'est une c'est une force de
police républicaine il faut seul et le
rôle des policiers gendarmes ou notre
pays et quand il ya des actes
individuels qui pose problème
que ce soit sur les des violences ou des
propos racistes a comme élu il faut
sanctionner durement et il faut dire que
en même temps il ya un malaise des
policiers contre les défenses de police
mais est ce que vous dites quand même
sur la clé d'étranglement sait on la
maintient non non moi je dis pas ça tant
qu'elle m'a dit qu'il est que cette
question là mais cette question-là l'est
posée depuis longtemps
non on parle d'art cours d'un retour au
teaser versements mais cette théorie oui
mais on l'a enlevé parce que c'était
dangereux on va enlever la crise est
vraiment parce que c'est dangereux c'est
un peu absurde c'est un peu le serpent
on serait le seul payant au monde à ne
pas savoir comment appréhender un une
personne ce n'est pas sérieux
dire que monsieur k salaire depuis trois
ans il a découvert que le le l'outil et
pistolet avec l'électricité c'était
problématique de telles mesures pardon
merci et la clé s'est posé problème
qu'est ce qu'on fait depuis qu'est ce
qu'il fait depuis trois ans ce malaise
là il existe déjà il est déjà réalisée
le 10 on est désarmé face à des délais
doublé donc collé la question qui est
posée c'est pourquoi le ministère
n'arrête pas depuis à travers notre
solution alternative est formel et
policiers parce qu'aujourd'hui ce que
réclament et policiers et des moyens
pour agir vraiment ce qu'ils n'ont pas
donc oui encore une fois ça normalement
qui feint d fed annonce puis qui revient
pas en arrière ça en sachant pas comment
faire parce que il annonce qu'il le
retire pour un set
mais tant qu'il n'y a pas autre chose on
le maintient donc tout ça n'est pas
sérieux
moi je pense que si il ya aujourd'hui on
le voit dans les études d'opinion
souvent avec entre la police notamment
la jeunesse c'est extrêmement grave
donc je pense qu'il faut pas les opposer
il faut dire que la jeunesse neuville sa
vie mais les forces de police sont là
pour nous protéger et donc ça veut dire
qu'un renouvellement de responsable
sérieux prendre décision en lien avec
les uns les autres et planifiée dans le
temps aujourd'hui on voit bien que ce ne
sont pas sérieux et ça crée encore une
fois des troubles dans l'autre ça
interroge en tout cas le recours à la
force par les autorités publiques adama
traoré la fère s'est passé dans votre
département vous soutenez vous comprenez
les manifestations organisées à l'appel
de la famille moi ce que je dis
simplement c'est que quand au bout de
quatre années ne sont toujours pas
expliqué comment un individu en l'espèce
adama traoré est décédé dans une
gendarmerie
ça pose problème et ça pose question je
crois que si dès le début on avait la
réponse il ya déjà quatre expertises
contradictoires et six gouvernements je
crois avait été un peu plus sérieux je
pense vous n'en serez là vous demander
la démission de christophe 80 le monde
aucune démission ce que je note c'est
que ça fait quatre ans que personne
c'est ce qui s'est passé je rêve ou
ferrer après je peux avoir s'ils
voulaient le débat sur plus largement
parce que vous évoquez la question du
racisme et discrimination
un débat mais je crois que vous n'êtes
pas beaucoup temps mais ça c'est une
vraie question par contre pour le coup
je vois pas de la fin de ma théorie mais
la question du racisme et de la lutte
contre les discriminations est un vrai
sujet après c'est dur et je crois à gré
police mais le racisme dans toute la
société est d'ailleurs les études
défenseur enfin les études du défenseur
droit le démontre et moi d'ailleurs je
dis à ma famille politique que c'est un
vrai sujet qu'il faut reprendre accord
une question puisqu'on a après la
démission de d'edouard philippe et de
son gouvernement
il y avait nécessité pour vous de
changer de gouvernement de donner un
nouvel élan à la majorité souvent après
élection municipale perdue
et là c'est une défaite c'est une
débâcle jamais impertinent parti au
gouvernement n'a perdu autant que la
plus qu'en marche le week-end dernier
il ya un changement mais une fois qu'on
aura passé pour celles et ceux qui sont
de leur téléphone attendent
et puis vous aurez vous à faire quelques
tribus en faisant un tel niveau il a
fait ça que tu as ça très sympa
la question c'est quelle politique et
quand je lis un terme du présent un
public hier dans la presse régionale
je ne vois pas de changement politique
au contraire je crois qu'il va continuer
vers toujours plus à droite
jour plus de libéralisme et je crois que
ça se terminera mal pour cette majorité
d'ailleurs et je le dis il faut
maintenir les élections à ce que quand
on dit aux français
il faut venir plus participer la
première chose qu'on ne fait pas c'est
de changer les élections je rappelle
parce que le prévenu qui souhaite
décaler sections départementales et
rejet d'un prévu dans neuf mois
alors que confirme qu'il renonce à
décaler les élections départementales et
régionales
oui mais ça enfin moi j'attendrais
devoir parce que comme il a dit aux
parlementaires qu'ils le feraient s'ils
renonçaient déjà en deux jours en trois
jours un changement de pied ce sera le
mot de la fin mercier à cheetah mal
merci
brigitte à 6 on trouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo
[Musique]